Following the huge success of Bird Box, the
apocalypse has returned to Netflix, though
this time it's a swarm of prehistoric-style
creatures that threaten to wipe out humanity.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing behind-the-scenes
secrets about the monsters in The Silence,
explaining who the sinister cult really are,
and I'll talk about how the movie compares
to A Quiet Place.
Plus I'll talk about how the movie compares
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care if
you haven't seen the film yet.
The Silence's pterodactyl-like monsters, the
Vesps, are unleashed when an archaeological
expedition opens up an uncharted cave system
deep in the mountains.
The Vesps are an undiscovered species that
had been sealed underground and so although
they're blind, they've evolved an acute sense
of hearing so they hunt their prey by sound.
The movie's producer said the filmmakers created
a mythology and back story for the monsters
where after they got stuck in the cave system,
the Vesps "adjusted to living life in darkness
with limited resources.
They evolved and developed the ability to
shut down their system into a sort of stasis,
and they didn't need a lot of fuel to stay
alive."
After the Vesps escape into the world above,
they have access to a lot more food and are
therefore able to reproduce much more quickly.
As Ally discovers when she and her father
are at the pharmacy, these creatures lay eggs
inside their victims.
The Vesps' physiology and design is inspired
by reptiles, bats, and birds, and they are
meant to be a naturalistic species that could
have evolved on Earth.
Director John Leonetti explained that they
researched "species that have been found in
caves over the years and used that to make
the Vesps' biology very realistic […]
Their skin is translucent, they have wings
and they fly, but they also crawl and lay
eggs like reptiles.
A lot of scientific research went into the
design, the creation, and the computer animation
of the creatures, right down to the detail
of every joint, every vessel, and every move
they make."
The filmmakers have also said the monsters
are definitely not aliens or creatures from
outer space, and they're named after the Spanish
word for wasps, avispas, as they tend to swarm
in large numbers, attacking their prey.
The Vesps' ability to evolve and reproduce
so quickly is their strength, and as we see
at the very end of the movie, even though
it's reported they don't like extreme cold,
some of them are now making their way north
and surviving.
Ally who made it to the Refuge, which is located
in a snowy, cold area, is now hunting down
Vesps which have invaded the territory.
And what's most scary is that the Vesps have
been laying their eggs in the animals they've
killed in the area, for example, this wolf.
It seems like a pretty grim apocalyptic ending,
but Ally suggests there is a possibility that
humanity could survive this disaster and beat
the monsters that are slowly overtaking the
world.
"So, will the rest of humanity evolve?
Will we adapt to this new world of silence
and remember what it is that separates us
from them?
Maybe.
I guess it's just a question of which of the
two species does it first."
According to Ally, she herself is proof it's
possible for humans to evolve.
After an accident where she lost her hearing,
she explains that her father was surprised
that she adapted so quickly.
And as a result of that, Ally and her family
learned to communicate with sign language,
which meant they seemed more equipped to live
in a world where silence means safety and
noise leads to danger, even death.
The final scene, which has a touch of The
Hunger Games about it, shows that Ally has
figured out one way to kill the creatures
is using a bow and arrow, which is obviously
much quieter than a gun.
That's also why earlier in the movie Hugh
fashioned a wooden spear as a weapon for Jude
to use.
At the end of the day, though, given how rapidly
the creatures seem to multiply laying so many
eggs, surviving families would really need
a larger scale solution such as the wood chipper
Ally's father used earlier in the film.
As well as the Vesps, The Silence also has
a group of human antagonists who the family
have to deal with.
Following Ally and her father's trip to the
pharmacy, they have their first encounter
with the creepy Reverend who tries to get
them to join his flock.
The Reverend leads a group or cult called
The Hushed who've cut out their own tongues
and later they turn up at the place where
Ally and her family are staying to pressure
them again to join their cult.
This time it's even more creepy though because
the Reverend reveals he's after Ally in particular
because she's fertile.
It's never stated explicitly, but it seems
the cult may be collecting young women to
use them to breed and swell their own numbers
and repopulate the earth after the Apocalypse.
By the way, this is a change from the original
book by Tim Lebbon where the cult wanted Ally
so they could learn to sign and communicate
silently.
The Hushed also seem to be part of a broader
religious reaction to the unleashing of this
apocalyptic world.
At one point in the movie when Ally is on
her tablet, we see headlines that say religious
extremists have been breeding the creatures
to hasten the end of the world or what they
see as Judgement Day.
They've also been burning atheists alive and
one preacher is reported as saying humanity
is the plague and Vesps are the cure.
In fact, when Ally calls her boyfriend Rob,
he's coughing and looks like he's holed up
somewhere trying to keep safe.
Rob tells Ally his parents are dead and I
wonder if that's because they've been attacked
by religious fanatics?
The Silence also plays on the idea of this
religious cult as terrorists when they send
a young girl into the house wearing a suicide
vest made up of cell phones ready to go off.
OK, so, you've no doubt heard a lot of people
saying this movie's a rip-off of A Quiet Place.
Before I explain why A Quiet Place is definitely
a much better film, it's worth noting that
The Silence was actually adapted from a book
written by Tim Lebbon which was published
before A Quiet Place came out, so it's not
a rip-off even if the premise is similar.
The way A Quiet Place executed the idea though
is much better.
It has a much tighter story focussing on just
one family with barely any other characters
or speaking in the movie and so the tension
in that film is really dialled up to the max
as the family avoids making even a tiny noise
for fear of attracting the monsters stalking
the land.
The Silence, by contrast, is all over the
place.
The family mostly talks even when they're
signing and the story moves way too quickly
taking the family from the suburbs, to the
countryside and then on to the Refuge in less
than 90 minutes, with a side plot of religious
extremism along the way.
On top of that, each death in A Quiet Place
has much more impact than those in The Silence.
That's because The Silence's characters are
underdeveloped so you don't care as much about
what happens to them, and although the religious
cult side story is potentially interesting,
it comes late in the film and feels rushed
through.
Also, many points which come up in the film
are left hanging, for example, the fact that
the electric grid and internet seems to be
randomly working and then sometimes not.
Is it because the creatures have been taking
down power lines?
I mean we see them massing on power lines,
or is it something else?
Like both A Quiet Place and Bird Box showed,
the idea of a creature preying on one of your
senses can set up a very interesting horror
movie and The Silence, like those two other
films, also has a good cast including Kiernan
Shipka, Stanley Tucci and Miranda Otto.
Unfortunately, they can only really do their
best with the material they're given which
doesn't live up to either A Quiet Place or
Bird Box.
A Quiet Place also did a great job casting
a talented deaf actress as one of the main
characters, whereas some in the deaf community
have criticised The Silence for using a hearing
actress in the role of Ally as well as for
an inconsistent and sometimes unrealistic
approach to both signing and lip reading and
the fact that there's much more to being deaf
than simply sign language.
On the positive side, The Silence does a decent
job with the design and look of the Vesps
and they do work quite effectively.
On that note, if you're interested in monster
design, tap here to check out my Quiet Place
Monsters Explained video.
So, what did you think of The Silence and
how it compares to A Quiet Place or Bird Box?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this and want more deep dives,
subscribe and hit the bell to get all my new
videos.
Tap left for my Quiet Place playlist including
deleted scenes and secrets from the movie
or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!